موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان مسلحين داخل سياره اطلق
النيران على سياره اسرائيليه عند مفترق
للطرق جنوب البحر الميت في منطقه الاغوار
ما ادى الى مقتل اسرائيلي واضاف في بيان
انه واصلوا التحرك نحو اريحا واطلقوا
النار واستهدفوا سياره ثانيه بينما كانوا
يغادرون المكان وقد تم نشر الحواجز
العسكريه وتجديد عمليات التفتيش حول اريحا
وقالت الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان العمليه تاتي
في اطار الرد على جرائم الاحتلال
ومستوطنين
هذا واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي وتعزيز قواته
في منطقه نابلس شماليه الضفه الغربيه
بكتبه عسكريه رابعه منذ بدء تعزيز قواته
في المنطقه الليله الماضيه ياتي قرار جيش
الاحتلال عقب مشاورات اجراها وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي مع قياده الجيش خلال جوله
تفقديه في موقع عمليه حوار التي اسفرت عن
مقتل مستوطنين اثنين وقد حملت السلطه
الفلسطينيه حكومه نتنياهو مسؤوليه هجمات
المستوطنين في حوار
وادانت الخارجيه الامريكيه ما سمته العنف
العشوائي الذي يشنه مستوطنون اسرائيليون
ضد الفلسطينيين واقل المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلاد هتتوقع من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ضمان المساءله
الكامله والمحاكمه القانونيه للمسؤولين عن
هذه الهجمات
مع اصرار الرئاسه التونسيه على انها تعمل
على تصحيح مسار الثوره قال الرئيس جبهه
الخلاص الوطني المعارضه ان الحمله القمعيه
الحاليه ضد المعارضين ليست سوى تجلي من
تجليات تخبط السلطه واعلن ان الجبهه ستنظم
مظاهره الاحد القادم للمطالبه بالافراج عن
المعتقلين السياسيين من جميع التيارات
تحتدم المعارك في مدينه اوكرانيا حيث
تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه الحفاظ على
مواقعها في المدينه من جهه قال زعيم
دونيتك الموالي لروسيا ان الظروف في جبهه
مواتيه لتطويق من سماه العدو من جانبه
قالت وكاله ريانوس
تخوض معارك في مركز المدينه وان جميع
الطرق المؤديه اليها اصبحت تحت السيطره
الناريه للقوات الروسيه
هذا واصلت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه الى
كييف زياره مفاجئه التقت خلالها الرئيس
الاوكرانيه واكدت له التزامه واشنطن بدعم
بلاده ياتي هذا في الوقت الذي اعلنت فيه
موسكو استعدادها للرد على العقوبات
الغربيه
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه قولها ان طائره عسكريه امريكيه
حلقت فوق مضيق تايوان وقالت الوكاله ان
الطائره الامريكيه وهي من طراز بي ثمانيه
عبرت المضيق من الشمال الى الجنوب دون
اعطاء مزيد من التفاصيل
قال الجيش الصيني وانه راقب الطائره
الامريكيه عن كتب وهي تحلق فوق المضيق
واضاف ان الامر يهدد الامن والاستقرار في
المضيق وشددت المؤسسه العسكريه الصينيه
على رفضها لهذا العمل الامريكي
في المقابل قال سفير الولايات المتحده لدى
الصين لدى بلاده مسؤوليه الحفاظ على قوتها
العسكريه في تايوان ومحيطها لضمان ردع اي
هجمات صينيه على الجزيره
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]